hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game
from the girlfriend challenge that we
started yesterday it's prayananda versus
a wonderling it's a game from round one
and it features a lot of very very
interesting moves
as you'll see uh so uh i i said in the
previous video that i would cover a few
more games from this one
and uh if you guys have any of the
suggestions that uh you
you have a favorite of your own you use
hashtag suggestion
uh so i can spot your your game in the
uh in the comments as a lot of games are
being played
in this event and uh one of these two
gentlemen is the uh
absolute winner of the first day after
the five rounds were played but i'm not
going to spoil it for you
let's just see what happens here so
pragananda with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have knight to f6 by
leaning we have
c4 uh e6 knight to c3 and bishop to b4
going for the nimzo indian defense
uh and now e3 so the the most common way
to treat this is uh
either queen to c2 or e3 there are there
are other moves but these are the most
popular ones we have castles
uh and now bishop to d2 uh we have b6
preparing to finca to the light square
bishop as well
uh and now knight to f3 uh with bishop
to b7
and now comes bishop to d3 so both
players just nicely
uh continuing development we have d5
striking in the center and now we have a
trade here we have captures captures
uh and rook to c1 we have a6
and the now castles and bishop back to
b6 now the
the bishop no longer has any purpose
here we have bishop back to d6 and now
uh the e5 square looks very nice for the
knight so knight to e5 and it's just a
beautiful piece there
uh you you never can really get rid of
this knight you you can either attack it
maybe knight here you can attack it
again but
white will always just reinforce the
knight with a move like f4
so here what black does is black will
try to undermine the center
uh from uh the flank so here's c5
attacking the center here
and uh f4 again so this knight is just a
monster here
there are some lines where you can kick
away the knight by moving this knight
and then playing f6 but
those are very rare so here knight to c6
attacking uh the knight once again and
now uh how do you
improve the position here for white
because all your pieces are kind of
ideally placed
well again we look at for the piece that
it does
doesn't really do all that much and
that's the dark square bishop here
so for the moment it's just a very bad
pawn so we want to shift it over to this
diagonal bishop to e1 to h4 and this is
exactly what
prague does he plays bishop to e1 and
now we have c captures on d4 and now
knight captures on c6 the the problem
with e captures on d4
uh is that now black can just capture
and there's uh well
not all that much you can do this does
not work bishop captures uh knight
captures and then you
recapture the knight here uh because
bishop the c5 will win your queen at the
end of this line
if you were wondering so instead we have
knight captures on c6 bishop captures on
c6
and now uh first knight to e2 you you
could recapture but first knight to e2
now with
an attack on the light square bishop
here uh we have bishop back to
bishop to b5 bishop back to d7 is a
known move here uh
up until this point these were all very
well known moves
but here we have bishop to b5 instead of
bishop to d7 and it is only now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game
so let's see how prague deals with this
he plays knight captures on d4
that's why he didn't capture with the
pawn now his spawns are still intact
here
we have bishop captures on d3 queen
captures and the knight
the e4 and now black is the one with the
monster knight here
but white has other plans knights to f5
uh white now has a an even nicer knight
it's hard to say how long it will be
able to stay here but it is a very
very uh nice night uh the problem is uh
the d5 pawn is hanging and also this
knight is just a menace here attacking
the bishop attacking g7
a lot of nice ideas here you can always
do a rook lift with something like rook
to c6
the problem is if you play something
like this just you know keep an eye on
everything
it doesn't really work just queen d4 we
threaten checkmate and after you prevent
this now you can go queen captures on c6
that's the the
problem queen captures queen captures on
d5 uh will now win the knight here and
after this we just have two pieces for a
rook which is now winning for white here
so uh instead after this knight to f5 we
have g6 balling
chasing away the knight knights to h6
check king to g7 and now comes queen
captures on d5 so grabbing that pawn
uh we have queen to e7 uh of course you
do not want to go after the knight if
you play something like king captures on
h6 then king capture the queen captures
on e4
uh you haven't really accomplished all
that much and your king is
very very weirdly placed here on h6 even
if you go back this bishop is coming to
c3
so it's a very very ugly position to
play so instead
instead after this queen captures and
the five queen the e7 was played
and now comes uh well a very interesting
moment in the game
uh that did not occur in the game uh
here uh
the knight is under attack and knight
back to g4 was played but maybe
uh white has some other move that he can
play so feel free to pause the video
here
really think about the position and tell
me or rather don't tell me because you
can't
talk to me directly but you can write in
the comments what would you play here
while while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those who were able to do it
congratulations on not going back
but rather going forward and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
queen captures and the i'm tricking you
again it's
knight captures on f7 uh and this is uh
what uh what could have been played the
problem is the knight cannot be captured
the queen cannot capture because then
this knight falls and you just want
material
uh it cannot be captured with the rook
because then the rook on
a8 falls it cannot be captured with the
king because the queen defends it
so here there's uh not
all that much black can do there is one
move black has
and it's probably why prague avoided
this line
uh it's a rapid game so you don't really
have all that much time to calculate
everything but i will just show it
because it's beautiful
and that is bishop to c5 so the the the
question is
what do you play here so now uh there
there's the thread of just bishop
captures on e3 grabbing
material here and then you don't have
all that much to show for with white
uh the problem is white has rook
captures on c5
uh and now knights to f6 by black first
attacking the queen and after the queen
moves we're going to capture the rook
here
uh and now comes bishop to b4 attacking
the queen and
the rook is still on f8 queen to d5
offering a queen trade
now we pick up the rook with check king
captures knight here
and now bishop back to b4 and now this
position
is on the board where you can either
keep the queens on the board uh get the
queens off the board you can play some
like rook the c8 you can trade here
uh all in all we would get this position
where white would be up two points and
it
would be uh quite a quite a significant
advantage but uh you know that's a
that's a
really really an incredibly difficult
line uh especially for a rapid game so
after queen to e7 we have just
knight goes back to g4 and now rook 8
d8 again liang gives prague a nice
opportunity uh he should play rook to c8
and prevented this and
this rook lift with rook to c4 he goes
rook to d8 and now again gives
prague a bit of a bit of a chance we
have rook to c4
now with a double attack on the knight
here rook after e8 adding a defender but
now comes
rook captures on e4 and this is crucial
here because the knight was a
uh well it was a decent defender of the
dark squares now bishop the c3
will hurt a lot so here queen captures
on e4 you don't have
any other move here bishop to c3 with
check
and now only one move king to f8 if you
go king to g8 then you get
the monster fork here and you're just
lost so instead after bishop to c3 check
king to f8 and now comes queen to g5
now with ideas of infiltrating with
queen to h6 uh for example queen h6 king
j892
uh f6 check king j8 and then we're just
gonna deliver checkmate so
such are white's plans however queen to
f5 now
kind of trying to trade off queens but
at least covering the
df6 square now but it still doesn't work
because the
the black king can always escape via the
e7 square and that's exactly what it
does if he goes
if he goes to the right then he's gone
so here queen to h6
check king to e7 and now bishop to
f6 with check so here uh if prague wants
he can win back material the rook here
will be hanging so king to d7 and now
comes the knight
to e5 with check not being greedy with
material but
just opening up more lines in front of
the black king
so here bishop captures on e5 we have f
captures and e5 still
with this uh pressure uh uh uh
towards the rook on d8 but rook to d1
and c1
uh will will be uh a lot for black to
handle
so here we have queen to e4 uh and now
comes bishop captures on the e8 here he
goes for the material
maybe he could have held on the pressure
a little bit more maybe some like queen
captures her queen captures here
but like i said it's a rapid game uh you
can't um
spend all that much time on the moves so
bishop captures we have king captures
and now rook captures an f7 another
another slight imprecision queen
captures on h7 is just much safer
it seems like brook captures is safer
because the queen here covers the e3
square but it's not here
if you just play queen captures and now
black is just in in a really really bad
position even if you give up these pawns
for example rook captures queen captures
and queen captures
you're gonna play king to h1 and now
black's king is completely wide open
your king is very much safe here you
don't have
weaknesses so it's not not really a
problem uh with the move in the game
rook captures an f7 prague again gives
uh
liam some some room to improve
so queen captures an e5 here as the
three pawn is now defended
and now comes queen to h4 the problem is
if you go for this
uh capture now now you don't have
anything on the back rank
defending your king so here just check
and that's it uh if you go back
you're gonna get checkmated and if you
block with the rook you're again
to get uh well just destroyed rook to f8
and there's no way to defend this
there's a double attack on the rook you
can deliver this check to kind of
try and defend your rook but still just
g5 and if queen g3
then we just deliver this check and now
it's going to be checkmate
so that's also on the board so here
queen to h for check was played
but now comes g5 just blocking this and
now
queen to d4 with check you might also
try to keep the tension with queen to c4
if the black queen ever
moves maybe you can deliver checkmate
but still it's very hard to play queen
captures an e3 king h1
and now we can just deliver queen to e1
check you can block but then we just
play
queen e2 offer a queen trade uh threaten
to capture the rook
and it's very hard to imagine white uh
doing more than a draw here especially
since it's a rapid game
so after this g5 move we have queen to d
for check instead and now uh we have a
trade queen captures
we have e captures on d4 and now just
rook to e2 here
liam now goes after the queen side pawns
and prague goes after the king side
pawns
we have rook captures on h7 rook
captures on b2
and now a3 so rook to a2 going after the
pawn
rook g7 we have rook captures on a3 and
now
rook captures on g5 so this is how
prague uh decided to play this he
couldn't spend more time to find all of
those moves but he said all right i'm up
upon now
uh this is either a win or a worst case
scenario or draw but
let's let's try and win this so here b5
liang starts pushing his pawn and
now h4 now we have b4 it's now a race
and now rook the g8 check first now you
will still be able to push your pawn but
also you can just shift your rook here
to keep an eye on black's past pawn
so king to c7 and now comes d5
and d5 is a move that does not work here
what works here is just continuing to
push your pawn but
again it's very hard to see such things
because after h5 and b3
now yes black's pawn is faster however
rook g7 checked
and now the thing is if you go uh king
to b6 or or somewhere like that you can
always play rook to g8 and then you will
always have this check if the pawn is
advanced then you can pick up the pawn
here
so it's very important to keep the king
at bay so to say
so after king to b6 you would play some
like like i said rook to
g8 and if king to b7 then you simply
continue checking and
you don't to give black the opportunity
to to push the pawn king c6
uh or rather even if king king to c6 we
can play d5 with
check just to push the king away from
the b7 square and now we can
continue pushing our pawn and this is
well with perfect play this would end in
a draw
however d5 was played here right away uh
prague decided to push the pawn first
for some reason
but this allows black a very sneaky
maneuver
now black does not push the pawn this
was uh prague's idea if black pushes the
pawn now we play rook to g7
with the same idea we can always shift
the rook behind the pawn keep an eye on
the b2 square
however here liang played rook to a5
and now all of a sudden your pawn is
hanging so what do you play here
uh here prague defended it with rook to
g5 but now rook to b5
just putting the rook behind the pass
pawn and what's even worse
black queens with check and the white
does not the black king is in c7
so here there is there isn't much you
can play h5 was played in the game with
b3
rook to g7 check but now just king to d6
and now it's clear that uh
there is no way for prague to get out of
this one rook the g6 checking d5
rook to g5 with king to e6 it doesn't
matter if you trade still the
uh black queen will join join the game
with check
so rook g6 check king to f7 now comes
rook captures on a6 and now
b2 we rook the a7 check king to g8 but
here yeah even though both of them
had uh some seconds on the clock there
really is no point in continuing this
uh because as soon as the black king
avoids the checks uh he's going to play
pawn to b1 and that's just going to be
it
yeah really an exciting one and yes uh
for those of you who are wondering here
are the standings and um
uh like i said one of these uh two
gentlemen uh
has a perfect score after the first day
i wonder liam won
all of his five games so five out of
five so that's really
an incredible achievement uh no dr
beckham satoru with four points out of
five then
we have gunema machada and the vincent
kymer with three and a half
and then um a series of of players with
three pragananda dinars
uh christopher yooni hassan gukesh and
ting july
and then a lot of other players with uh
below three points so it's still only
the first day team polgar as you can see
is leading
by 26 to 24 so we will see what happens
um
until the until the end of the
tournament uh but yeah so far a very
very exciting
event and a lot of really really awesome
games are being played because
these are young players and this is a
rapid time format so you know uh games
will be
quite quite explosive uh so uh prague
had a great start to the game he had
many many chances but
uh wanderling is just a very very
slippery it would seem
and he avoided all of his uh ideas and
in the end he just
uh you know one won an endgame rook's
end game being upon down so that
that kind of tenacity really really
deserves a five out of five
uh on day one uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank uh
mainz ma henrik fola david kimura
michael sakri
zakarias and derek lee for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing with
a few more games from this tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else uh happens
in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day